We see in the first quadrant all trigonometric functions are positive and that's because
well the opposite side, the adjacent side and the hypotenuse of any triangle
you're trying to draw will also be positive.
We saw that quadrant II only designs positive, let's think quadrant III.
Let's imagine this giant angle.
Well, to talk about this angle, we're going to think about the smaller version
of the angle and we're going to make a right triangle.
Now, if this right triangle the opposite side goes below this zero line, so it's negative,
and the adjacent side goes to the left of this zero line so it's also negative.
I want to know in the third quadrant, which trig function is positive.
Is it the sine, the cosine, the tangent, all of them or none of them?
Choose your best answer, and this is tricky, but remember think of what happens
when you perform the divisions required of each of these trigonometric ratios.
Also to remind that the hypotenuse is always positive.